[Applause]
[Music]
we welcome you back to planet earth and
thanks for flying spacex
big round of applause in order for this
one after a nearly six-month stay on the
international space station
a spacex dragon capsule carrying four
astronauts
splashed out early yesterday look at
that off the northwest coast of florida
now this was the first nighttime
splashdown
for a u.s crew in more than 52 years
that's a big old wow
this capsule will make history again
this fall when it carries the first
all-civilian space crew into orbit
for the first inspiration for mission
mark straussman introduces us to the
four americans
who will be on board there's the crew
255 feet above historic launch pad
39a we met the crew of inspiration four
the next astronauts to climb atop a
rocket at spacex's launch tower
this is like totally sacred ground
everyone who ever walked on the moon
launched right from this facility jared
isaacman
the mission's commander walked us down
the crew access arm
their gateway to the stars there's your
like jetway to the rockets
isaac min is 38 at 16
he quit high school to form a payments
technology company
and became a billionaire his hobby
owning and flying fighter jets so when
the new commercial era of space opened
you thought
i'm a customer well i mean i thought
there would be a chance
ignition he's chartered a crew dragon
spaceship
for three days flying on autopilot it
will orbit more than 300 miles above
earth
higher than the space station the nose
cone will pop
open for views that are out of this
world isaac been paid spacex an
undisclosed price for all four seats
three
will go to complete strangers when i
found out that inspiration four was
going to be
the first all-civilian mission to space
well then there's no chance
that's going to be a bunch of fishing
buddies going on a joyride that's
something of significance of
responsibility
and we were going to make it really
special each seat will represent
a human virtue isaacman's will be
leadership
he donated two of the three remaining
seats to saint jude children's research
hospital
in memphis specialists in pediatric
cancers
st jude called me one day they said they
had something to talk to me about haley
arsenau's 29
this physician's assistant at saint
jude's would become the youngest
american
ever to fly in space they asked if i
wanted to go
and immediately i said yes and then you
know checked with my mom
she was on board and so i i
knew just from that moment that i was
absolutely something like a dream i
didn't even know i had
this is haley in 2002 as a
patient at st jude's she was 10
being treated for osteosarcoma
bone cancer she recovered after chemo
and surgery with a titanium rod in her
left thigh bone
she now works at the same hospital that
saved her life
her seat in the capsule will represent
hope
so we're going to call the saint jude
patients from space they're going to see
that somebody who is in their shoes
who also fought childhood cancer can go
to space and i think it's really going
to show them what they're capable of
yeah that's pretty amazing cyan proctor
aptly named teaches science at a
community college in phoenix
did you think your space dream was over
oh absolutely
the 51 year old was once a finalist for
nasa's astronaut program
but ultimately passed over proctor's
ticket to space aboard inspiration 4
came by winning a contest for
entrepreneurs her seat represents
prosperity you went from space not being
in the stars to suddenly it was
what was that moment like i'll never
forget it i'd make that analogy of
either willy wonka
and you open up the chocolate bar and
there's the golden ticket or
harry potter learning he's a wizard so
jared was the sorting hat for you
he was gryffindor no it's a dragon i get
to ride a dragon into space
this is where everybody got on their
rocket to go
chris sombrowski a 41 year old engineer
from seattle
won the fourth seat through an online
raffle to raise money for saint jews
he actually lost the raffle but a friend
won
and gave him the chance now that's
generosity
the virtue his seat represents and then
i ran upstairs after the call and talked
to my wife and said
honey i i'm going to ride a rocket and
her response was
what and my daughter who was sitting
there said that's awesome that's really
cool dad
this space flight will make history
issacman also hopes
it makes money as a fundraiser for saint
jews
his goal raised 200 million dollars for
the hospital
we have a responsibility to take care of
some of these problems here on earth if
we're going to go and explore among the
stars
and you've given 100 million dollars
yourself i have now i know how lucky
i've been in life the ball's bounced my
way many times
and some of these families have been
dealt just a horrible hand in life so we
got to do something about it that's why
it has to be such a big initiative
for cbs this morning mark strossman at
the kennedy space center
i love that honey mom yeah go into space
on this space i heard isaac mendoza
wow i love all the thought he put into
every single aspect of this mission and
they all match their stories too
exactly the hope the prosperity the
generosity leadership
wow it's a special thing that little
capsule on top of the giant rocket it's
mostly just rocket fuel i'm literally
getting chills in the middle of that
would either one of you want to go i
definitely don't would do it i admire
them
do it you would yeah oh for sure and i'm
sure vlad duterte would as well he'll be
here next
yeah we'll ask him about it stay with